Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Imaginen la película
más apocalíptica que hayan visto.
La primera escena es una vista aérea
de la tierra arrasada y el mar renegrido.
La mitad de la población mundial
lucha contra la otra mitad
por falta de comida,
en un lugar desértico.
4000 millones de personas
viven en zonas
en donde no pueden cultivar
nada para comer
y no tienen suficiente agua
para sobrevivir.
Inundaciones y sequías;
temperaturas insoportables.
Nuevas enfermedades que nos atacan;
incendios forestales.
Huracanes muy frecuentes.
Migraciones masivas.
Cientos de millones
de refugiados ambientales.
Saqueos de supermercados
multiplicados por miles en todas partes.
Cortes de electricidad.
Sistemas financieros
y de comunicación caídos.
Desabastecimiento de agua,
de combustible y de medicamentos.
Un millón de especies desaparecen
y no por una extinción más,
sino por la primera aniquilación
biológica producida por una sola especie.
Pero ¿saben qué?
Esto no es ciencia ficción.
Esta es una catástrofe
ecológica y climática.
Y es el mundo de los próximos 10 años.
Vos en la fila uno no te vas a salvar.
Vos en la cinco tampoco.
Vos detrás de la cámara, tampoco.
Yo tampoco.
Porque no importa dónde nos sentemos.
El colapso nos va a llevar puestos igual
si durante la próxima década
no transformamos nuestro
sistema de producción y consumo,
si no revertimos el avance de la ganadería
y de la agricultura industrial,
y cortamos a la mitad el uso de petróleo.
Esto es cambiarlo todo, o casi todo.
Hoy tengo un par de minutos
para alertarles
sobre la gravedad terminal
de nuestra situación.
Solo un par de minutos
para que se convenzan
de que esto no es una teoría de complot.
De que estamos realmente frente
a la peor de todas las crisis.
Nuestra civilización tal cual
la conocemos va a dejar de existir
durante los próximos 10 años.
Y no son responsables de esto
las 4000 millones de personas
que pueden morir.
Los principales responsables
de haber llegado a esta situación
son quienes están más preparados
para enfrentar el pronóstico apocalíptico
porque escuchan a la ciencia.
Los más ricos y poderosos
están diseñando sus refugios familiares
para sobrevivir al colapso.
Cuenta un exgerente
de una famosa red social
que cuando comenzó a compartir
con sus colegas de Silicon Valley
los detalles de su pequeño
proyecto de isla,
todos comenzaron a salir del closet
y a blanquear sus planes
para la supervivencia.
En este preciso momento
están comprando territorios en altura.
Pueblos enteros con abundancia natural.
Construyendo búnkeres, instalando
generadores, paneles solares,
y diseñando las milicias para su defensa.
Están "blindando" sus islas privadas.
Enfrentamos un escenario inevitable
de fragmentación social violenta.
Y hasta las Naciones Unidas lo definió
sin tapujos como "apartheid climático".
Los ricos salvándose.
Y la mayor parte de la humanidad
empujada a sobrevivir.
Existe absoluto consenso
de la comunidad científica.
Superar la barrera de aumento
de la temperatura global
en más de 1,5 °C
es colapso ecosistémico masivo.
Después de los incendios de Amazonas
alcanzaremos los 2 °C
durante la próxima década.
Y gracias a 25 años
de negociaciones diplomáticas fallidas
estaremos en 7 °C antes de fin de siglo.
¿Cómo puede ser que nuestros gobiernos
que tienen toda esta información
no hagan nada?
Hay algo con buscar las soluciones
dentro del sistema,
que no está funcionando.
Yo misma siento que fallé.
Fallé como activista durante 20 años
porque, evidentemente, todas
las formas de activismo fallaron.
Fueron insuficientes.
Hace muy poco tomé real dimensión
de esta finitud tan cercana.
Me desesperé y me llené de ansiedad.
Sabía que nada de lo
que hiciera iba a ser suficiente.
También me di cuenta
de que personas queridas
cuando les hablaba de esto
se iban a otro lado.
O suspiraban y me cambiaban de tema.
Cómo las voy a juzgar,
quizás fuera mejor disfrutar
de la vida antes del colapso.
Pero no pude.
Me fue imposible
seguir como si nada pasara.
Entonces llegó el dolor
y las ganas de llorar.
Aunque no fue lo único.
Lentamente algo más fue surgiendo
desde el fondo de esa tristeza.
Dejé de obligarme a tener esperanza
y apareció en mi una furia
que me energizó.
Me aceleró el corazón
y me llevó a la acción.
Porque lo que necesitaba no era esperanza.
Lo que necesitaba era coraje.
Coraje para cuestionarlo todo.
Para hacerme una pregunta prohibida:
¿Por qué tenemos que obedecer las reglas
del sistema que nos está exterminando?
¿Es lógico seguir alentando
la producción ganadera y agrotóxica?
Si sabemos que devasta
comunidades y ecosistemas enteros.
¿Es justo que nuestros impuestos subsidien
proyectos petroleros de fracking?
La extracción no convencional
de combustibles fósiles
acelera el desastre climático.
Las complicidades de las instituciones
me duele en las entrañas.
Pero no es la primera vez que somos
testigos de un genocidio silencioso.
En otros momentos de la historia
existieron procesos de exterminio masivo
que buscaron ser ocultados
por las autoridades.
Esta vez tenemos que desafiar
a la autoridad injusta a tiempo
porque cuando las leyes
y las instituciones no nos protegen,
el contrato social desaparece.
Y los ciudadanos adquirimos
el derecho y el deber
a la desobediencia civil.
(Aplausos)
Quizá se pregunten si lo que planteo
es una suerte de rebelión.
Lo que planteo es que este modelo
es autodestructivo.
Porque está fundado en negar
los límites físicos del planeta.
Y si no es suficiente con que
lo digan las Naciones Unidas
o lo plantee yo acá,
vayan a las redes.
Está lleno de fuentes confiables.
Pero frente a esta verdad científica,
los gobiernos nos responden que
es política y socialmente imposible
cambiar tan rápido.
Sin embargo ya hemos protagonizado
cambios radicales
en momentos de emergencia
que parecían imposibles.
Por ejemplo, durante las guerras.
Esta es la emergencia más enorme
a la que nos hayamos enfrentado.
Nos quedan menos de 10 años
para una transformación
de proporciones épicas,
que no vamos a conseguir solamente
poniendo molinos eólicos, paneles solares,
reciclando o reduciendo nuestro
consumo individual de carne.
Necesitamos la movilización de
personas más grande de la historia.
Quienes han estudiado el éxito
de los movimiento civiles de resistencia
demostraron que
si el 3,5 % de la población
sostiene en el tiempo estrategias
de disrupción pacífica
llevando a las calles un reclamo justo,
podemos sacudir a un sistema
que se niega a escuchar.
La desobediencia civil no violenta
ha sido el método más efectivo
a lo largo de la historia reciente para
lograr cambios sistémicos y radicales.
Existen muchos ejemplos bien conocidos.
Rosa Parks, Martin Luther King, Gandhi,
las colectivas de mujeres
que exigieron y lograron el voto femenino
y hoy siguen dando luchas imprescindibles.
Nuestro país tiene experiencias hermosas
de desobediencia civil pacífica y exitosa.
Principalmente en la ruralidad.
El pueblo de Malvinas Argentinas,
en Córdoba,
bloqueó la instalación
de Monsanto en su tierra
instalando durante cuatro años
la disrupción colectiva.
La comunidad de Famatina, en La Rioja,
lleva más de una década expulsando
a las mineras más grandes del mundo
a pesar de las reglas
y las normas escritas.
No hay gradualismo cuando estamos
luchando por nuestra supervivencia.
Los fenómenos de
transformación planetarios
no se van a detener por una ley.
No podemos frenar con un decreto
a las millones de personas
que estarán cruzando fronteras escapando
de fenómenos climáticos extremos.
Quizás en este momento
estén queriendo volver al mundo
que conocían hace 10 minutos.
Pero no tengo alternativa.
No tenemos alternativa.
Con creatividad y sin violencia
tenemos que salir a la calle
para cambiarlo todo.
La transformación tiene que empezar hoy.
Y tiene que ser enorme, desproporcionada,
más allá de lo posible.
La única decisión que podemos tomar
en estos momentos de incertidumbre
es qué hacer con el tiempo que tenemos.
Nadie lo va a hacer por nosotros.
El poder real nos pertenece,
abracémoslo, con amor y furia.
El tiempo no es mucho.
Y para que sea justo,
debe ser desobediente.
(Aplausos)